[Music]
Sarah it is
me and I got this
[Music]
Mor I love my
mother I hate my brother
so let's get after it and have us a good
time a good [__] bread
guys so stupid Chris KO he is is not
only he's back and not only is he is he
back back is he back in POG form well
actually that does look like a Pog it
does and not only is he back in POG form
merch but uh he's reading his YouTube
comments again that's never good and not
only is he reading his YouTube do that
Chris he's reading his YouTube comments
about
UFOs what yeah Little Green Men no why
don't you why don't you read the YouTube
comments about the bird was the bird
Chris aliens are small and green like an
olive this [__] bird murdering grease
ball men no no no all of these pushes
about you UFOs and our coverage at news
Nation are about what is news nation is
that the thing that Bill O'Reilly's on
transparency your government's
responsibility to take the power that
you have given them and be held to
account what do they know what do they
not and I love how he how he went from
being just a mouthpiece of the DNC to
being middle of the road Chris Coro I'm
middle of the road guy middle of the
road guy and like you know we all got to
come together like he really just thinks
he's insightful he's bringing a he's
bringing people together God damn why
that's what it's about I'm Chris Cuomo
thank you very much for being here for a
special episode of the Chris Cuomo
project your comments your concerns on
the specific issue of UFOs and where my
head is about why it matters you know
why he's doing you know why he's doing
topical comment
reading cuz all the other ones are
bullying him or asking him where the
bird is still yeah we all know what the
what all the the bulk of the com we know
what the real comments are yeah it's
literally like 500 comments of people
calling him a [__] bird murdering
meatball and then it's like two or three
like what do you think about UFOs and
he's like all we'll do the UFO
one hey The Cho project it's still the
best hold on hold
on hold on and get it just right the
chomo project right here the chomo
project our next partner how many
stingers do you need well this is a
stinger for his live read so we're going
to go and skip that it's like the
beginning of an indie movie with all the
production companies there's like 40 of
them whoa he has two live reads at the
beginning Chris I don't know who's
teaching you
YouTube but you could have one live read
after an intro that's fine but you
cannot do backtack you could do
back-to-back live reads in an in in a in
a [__] uh clip but but but they can't
be back to back they have to be spread
out and some would say even that's
pushing it I even know I don't even like
the ones that kick off right away with a
[__] sponsor because you're like you
haven't even done anything yet yeah that
annoys me a lot of True Crime channels
are doing that now well they'll be like
you know ah woman vanishes and ver
Vermont and we have the case here blah
blah blah but first I want to tell you
about League Shadow Legend Shadow legend
woman a woman vanishes in Vermont and if
you want to vanish those wrinkles we
have this new cream you like could you
at least get halfway through before you
start dropping [__] live
reads hi Mr Cuomo I'm calling because it
says here if you've had any UFO you that
sounds like when the scam biters use
like the girl voice to fool people Chris
Coma got a voice modulator just pessy
with his voice modulator pessy talking
like a girl with his voice mod I was
just gonna say it just sounds like Chris
K with his nose plugged like hi I'm just
wondering if uh you've been talking
about
UFOs yeah hly you're much better looking
than your brother you're very handsome
oh have you been working out your guns
are beautiful pessy do you have the girl
voice yeah hold on I was going to point
out to like you know imagine what a
[__] loser you'd have to be to leave
a voicemail for the Chris Cuomo YouTube
show but now imagine you're such a
[__] loser that you're calling the
Chris Cuomo voicemail to talk about UFOs
yeah this is long time F chice I'm a
lady I was wondering if you are you know
f b you know [__] aliens and all the
like the UFOs and the you know little
space men the
[__] thank you well Chris Chris Chris
what do you have to say Chris D and they
suck the something out of your brain and
put you back and um so I'm glad it was
oh suck my what
P I'm not a f bro they're calling him
Joy of sexy in the chat are you telling
me so you tell me these aliens what
they're like or something gay aliens
yeah they trying to suck things out of
me
yeah um and I share your disappointment
except except I'd rather be on the
road uh to disclosure than not on the
road to disclosure so yes I was hoping
for more yes I wanted Congress to turn
the screws on NASA yes uh I hope that
they get the skiff yes I wanted to hear
more but it was better than nothing and
that's where we started so I'll take it
as a step uh the next step is obviously
more important in terms of the nature
and degree of disclosure and again for
me it's not about Little Green Men if
there's you know Proof of Life uh Beyond
us I would not be surprised I think it's
very arrogant to believe that we're the
only ones that were so he's just been
reading books in his off time huh I'm
sorry he's been listening to audio books
in his off time Poss love it in a
universe that he doesn't read books he's
been reading like the magazines you get
at the grocery store oh yeah like bat
boy found in
Wisconsin or like time yeah he listens
to magazines on
tape he ever
expanding but but but whatever you know
what you got the this this month's Time
Magazine audio book look just I'm
driving you know so I can't really read
look how easy it is to get a [__]
plaque from YouTube if you come from
mainstream media like he's got a YouTube
plaque look how easy it is to get one
found I think that there or if you kill
your son with the V yeah that helps be
more information about it at least to
our
leaders so that they can explain it to
us I get that some of the stuff is
confidential you got it from China you
don't want them to know although I'd be
shocked that they don't right because if
they send it over here yo if you guys
listen to this show Coast to Coast yeah
you heard of this guy Rell something
Rell this guy's great I found some clips
on YouTube I gotta love this [__]
guy it didn't come back obviously
they're going to be
aware they can do better and I think
it's symptomatic of a problem in our
government he had the flex a little for
everybody and our governance in general
and it's got to be fixed and it's got to
be better and that's what sorry the
ejacuation the issue is
to Chris this is Shane it's about the uh
show you Jeremy Corell what everybody's
not understanding oh yeah Chris this is
Shane a different [__]
guy yeah doing it's is Shane n totally
not your
neighbor you hear him through the walls
being picked up through the
microphone hey Chris how you doing this
is Shane and uh I was just wondering
what you Jeremy Corbell interview uh did
you guys get along off the air and also
can you bring my lawn mower back I said
you could borrow it not keep it
marrow that it's been a race between us
and whoever's out there they got to our
planet they found life they're
experimenting on listen they found life
not if they found the Como project they
didn't I can I can hear the pizza grease
through the oh yeah oh yeah you can what
they're doing can you go back I want you
to hear that I want you to hear when he
talk found life they found life I'm
going back I'm going
back
oh between us and whoever's out there
they got to our planet they found life
they found life they found a Virgin
Mary he's doing the side of the
Cross and that life was Tony Soprano the
man who sent me to hell and that's the
man who sent me into space
look I don't care about these aliens as
long as they believe in the pope and
mother Mary I'm fine with
them look as long as these aliens are
cra Christian yeah exactly they came
here for G they came here to get Jesus
cuz their Planet didn't have Jesus and
US did that's right the Italians gave
the aliens Jesus and sto masonry Chris
I'm GNA hang up and let you
answer hey Chris when are you gonna come
by the nights to Columbus have a
drink [__]
[__] they're experimenting on us
they're doing what they're doing have we
found anything anywhere else
certainly not on this YouTube
channel Chris I got a question what if
it's not aliens it's just like I don't
know fancy Jews or
something I'll hang up and
listen oh hey hey Chris is it true what
that uh margarine Thea green says about
you know the moon and the lasers and the
Jewish folk and all
that you know I got to be hon honest
with you though her personal record is
squats is pretty impressive
Chris is it true that they got those
Jewish space lasers and Chris is like I
don't know like you know when I left
here Z zck had a prototype but it wasn't
working yet I'm still waiting for that
to be the big reveal in Starfield
starbor or ju juice juice with a space
laser I wish you would love that on
there we're experimenting people are not
understanding this it's real call me I
got more for you call me I got more for
Shane's a problem you got more for I
don't know you have anything for Shane's
Shane's a problem right there he's like
he's literally Stan I love this call me
bro we'll hang out uh you got to have
proof of these things this idea that
well what would we do if we were
somewhere else that's what they how do
you know you didn't call them call Shane
call Shane new thing in the comments
section for Chris Chromo video ask him
if he's ever going to call Shane back
that's all I want to know he going to
call Shane I want to know about the
aliens ask him if he'll call Shane back
make accounts called that are just
called Shane be like hey man you going
to call Meen heard from me yet hey man
that would be [__]
brilliant he get this poor guy arrested
yeah that assumes there is someone else
that we know is doing but [__] it Chris
it's just Chris doing the phone call
anyway he has to play along like it's a
real guy this guy keeps bugging
me something else I know Jeremy has a
lot of conviction on this issue and I'm
happy to talk to him about it but I
believe that you only know what you show
so I don't want to engage in some
discussion that's completely man Roy
it's going to end up this whole thing
where he's out to dinner with his family
but he's also having dinner with someone
as Shane and he has to keep switching
between the costumes and then he sits
down at his family dressed like Shane
and they're like what's going
on what a wacky uh series of
events comedy of error Mr dauk I like
yes would we do if we all right I want
to hear what space Fredo has to say
let's hear him find another thing
Fredo's good I'm
smart CU we do you know dissecting and
experiments on can we get a mod and get
Chris Cuomo in Starfield please thank
you oh I'm trying to get the
[Applause]
artifact a fully voiced mod of Chris
KOMO but merch does all the voices look
you got no way understanding what you
even
got all right hey
look I know what you thinking this is
derivative Skyrim but honestly the
mechanics are fun the mechanics are fun
yeah it's just it's just Skyrim with no
story so Skyrim the way I play it I hear
you so why all right I get you it's not
although I'll give it to Starfield they
they you know you think wow I'm gonna
have this big epic adventure no they
just made a very realistic simulation of
what it would be like to travel through
space yeah that's true very large and
Barren and there's no story did you did
did I show you the did I show you the uh
merch if uh if bethesa made cyberpunk
video no okay reasonable or impossible I
just want to get on the proof train you
know what I'm saying truth train let's
get proof of what it is let's have them
understand uh if they've been able to
identify things want get on the that
come from other countries uh or whatever
their origin is I just think to the
extent that there's more to be sh it
should be shared that the idea that our
presumption is that the government
doesn't have to tell us anything is a
bad and false premise yeah but you want
to start with alien this is Brian hey
this is Brian this is totally not
Shane just to be clear this is totally
that Shane guy sucks but you should call
me though and it's like him just Shane's
just trying to trick him into calling
him I pretty much like to listen to you
because you do have both sides but the
UFO thing
I really think that it's going to do the
same it's always done we bring it up we
get the good things happening and then
all of a sudden everything starts to get
buried under again and they hope they
hope the establishment hopes that we
forget what do you can we do this can we
Round Up and Kill Everyone who's wasting
energy thinking about UFOs yeah I'm fine
with that I'm 100% behind that it is the
world is on fire all around you and
you're like what if there's little space
you're [__] fat you should die alone
in your apartment
sir